AS WE GO
TO OUR NEXT GAME, OTHER
BRITISH GRIEVANCES.
ON JULY 4TH, 1776 HEROIC
AMERICANS RISKED THEIR LIVES
TO BREAK FREE FROM THE
BRITISH TYRANNY AND TODAY
WE COMMEMORATE THEIR
SACRIFICE BY BINGE DRINKING
MICHELOB UNTIL SOMEONE
BLOWS OFF THEIR THUMB
WITH A [BLEEP] ROMAN CANDLE.
OF COURSE, THE BRITISH ARE IN
OUR COOL BOOK NOW BECAUSE OF
WORLD WAR II AND THE BEATLES,
BUT
LET'S NOT FORGET WHAT A
[BLEEP] KING GEORGE WAS BACK
IF THE DAY--THE THIRD ONE,
KING GEORGE THE THIRD.
ALL RIGHT, FOR EXAMPLE, HE
PLUNDERED OUR SEAS, RAVAGED
OUR COAST, BURNED OUR TOWNS
AND DESTROYED THE LIVES OF
OUR PEOPLE.
WE ARE ABSOLVED FROM OUR
ALLEGIANCE TO THE BRITISH
CROWN.
[BLEEP] YEAH, AMERICA.
>> THAT IS-- THAT IS A
[BLEEP]TON OF GRIEVANCES, AND
IT WAS WRITTEN 239 YEARS AGO
SO, THERE MUST BE SOME MORE
RECENT STUFF THE BRITISH DO
TO PISS US OFF.
IN THE SPIRIT OF OUR
NATION'S INDEPENDENCE, GIVE
US UPDATED BRITISH-- OH MY
GOD, YOUR HAIR.
PLEASE GIVE US SOME UPDATED
OTHER BRITISH GRIEVANCES
IN 60 SECONDS AND BEGIN.
>> ARDEN.
>> THEY HAVE ALLOWED
"CUMBERBATCH" TO BE A LAST
NAME.
>> POINTS.
>> IS THAT SHEERAN KID
BRITISH?
>> I THINK SO.
>> POINTS.
>> CALLING A PRESIDENT
A PRIME MINISTER?
>> COME ON.
>> SIMON COWELL'S POINTY
NIPS.
THEY'RE SO POINTY.
>> A TRAVESTY.
>> POINTS.
>> WHAT ABOUT [BLEEP]
MUMFORD AND SONS?
>> POINTS.
>> I ALWAYS HATED "ABSOLUTELY
FABULOUS."
>> WHAT?
>> NO, THAT'S A GOOD SHOW.
>> YOU'RE [BLEEP] WRONG.
>> YOU'RE WRONG AGAIN.
JUST LIKE YOU WERE WRONG
ABOUT "NATIONAL TREASURE."
>> TOOTH ROT.
>> POINTS.
>> THEY SMOKE FAGS AND EAT
DICKS.
(LAUGHTER)
POINTS.